[Música]
recta final en la campaña por la
presidencia de Brasil a menos de una
semana de las elecciones una nueva
encuesta le da la victoria al
expresidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
con el 50% de los votos frente a un 43%
del mandatario Yair bolsonar
en Venezuela a 4 subió el número de
Muertos tras un deslizamiento de tierra
en la ciudad de maracay y que se produjo
en medio de las intensas lluvias que han
azotado al país durante las últimas
semanas provocando inundaciones y
derrumbes ampliamos desde Caracas
nuevas sanciones de Estados Unidos a
Nicaragua más de 500 personas vinculadas
al gobierno del presidente Daniel Ortega
no podrán Ingresar a territorio
estadounidense a medida según Washington
se da por lo que califica como un ataque
a las instituciones democráticas Tenemos
reporte
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en francés 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Brasil en la recta final de los comicios
en la localidad de Nova Santa Rosa los
bolsonaristas quieren convertirse en un
bastión del mandatario y tu convertirse
también en el pueblo que le dé la
reelección Marina sardina tiene los
detalles
las últimas encuestas dan una ligera
Victoria al candidato izquierdista Luis
Ignacio lulada Silva pero en este pueblo
de Brasil en el Estado de Paraná tienen
una meta convertirse en el campeón del
voto por el ultraderechista Yair
bolsonaro
Nova Santa Rosa es una ciudad colonizada
por alemanes gente que valora a la
familia el cristianismo todo esto que
predica nuestro presidente Yair
bolsonaro el apoyo a la agronegocio el
apoyo a las empresas Así que esto hizo
que nuestra gente votara masivamente a
bolsonaro
fossil votar macizamente ahí no hubo
sonar Y es que la localidad ya votó
masivamente al presidente bolsonaro en
la primera vuelta de los comicios
presidenciales el pasado 2 de octubre
con el 82% de los votos logrando el
segundo porcentaje más alto del país Los
fervientes Seguidores del mandatario
están presionando en las calles para
lograr una victoria aún mayor con una
campaña basada en el miedo frente a su
rival Lula da Silva encontrar un cartel
del partido de los trabajadores es casi
Misión Imposible
es el miedo es el miedo que creo que
tienen todas las madres todos los padres
todos los brasileños de tener a sus
hijos en manos del PT porque vemos que
es muy liberal muy liberal está muy muy
liberado según los servidores del
candidato de extrema derecha bolsonaro
prometió visitar la localidad que más
votos le dé en los comicios de este
domingo y esta región agrícola con
grandes plantaciones de soya está
dispuesta a llevar al mandatario a la
reelección
vamos a Venezuela a cuatro subió el
número de víctimas mortales tras un
deslizamiento de tierra en la ciudad de
maracay así lo confirmó el
vicepresidente del partido gobernante
diosdado cabello las lluvias
torrenciales que han azotado durante
varias semanas al país han causado
numerosos derrumbes e inundaciones en
varias regiones de acuerdo con cifras
oficiales al menos 79 personas han
muerto en los dos últimos meses desde
Caracas la ampliación con nuestra
corresponsal Daniela Zambrano
la fuertes precipitaciones afectaron
también a la capital venezolana este
lunes en el barrio 23 de enero uno de
los más emblemáticos ubicados en el
oeste de Caracas las autoridades
tuvieron que desalojar al menos 42
familias luego de que varias viviendas
colapsaran y afectaran a más de 100
personas en los altos mirardinos se
registraron desbordamiento de quebradas
que afectaron no solo viviendas sino
también arrasaron múltiples vehículos
sin duda uno de los estados más
afectados ha sido el estado aragua este
lunes Se confirmó que ascendió a 4 el
número de fallecidos tras el
desbordamiento del río castaño que
recordemos la semana pasada afectó esta
zona y el pasado 8 de octubre también en
el estado aragua en tejerías
Lamentablemente 54 personas fallecieron
tras el desbordamiento de cinco
quebradas otro de los estados bastante
afectados ha sido Mérida el gobernador
reportó que al menos 60.000 familias Aún
se encuentran sin acceso a agua potable
pues varios diques colapsaron también
por la Fuertes lluvias el pronóstico no
es el Instituto Nacional de meteorología
prevé lluvias en las próximas horas y en
los próximos días producto del paso de
las ondas tropicales
triunfo para los ambientalistas en
Ecuador un grupo de residentes de Quito
entregó al consejo nacional electoral
unas 380,000 firmas para convocar un
referendo destinado a frenar proyectos
mineros para ello eran necesarias sólo
200.000 los activistas buscan bloquear 6
con sesiones de minería de oro en el
bosque del chocó andinos citando
amenazas a las fuentes de agua la
naturaleza y sus negocios locales el
presidente Guillermo lasso Apuesta por
el sector minero para impulsar la
economía de este país pero sus planes se
han visto interrumpidos por resoluciones
judiciales y plebiscitos a favor de
comunidades locales y pueblos indígenas
el 26 de Marzo inició un estado de
excepción en El Salvador que siete meses
después se mantiene desde el gobierno
aseguran que quieren extenderlo otros
seis meses y detener a los 30.000
pandilleros que siguen prófugos hasta
hoy se han producido 55.000 detenciones
las organizaciones denuncian que muchas
son arbitrarias y que 80 personas han
muerto en prisión sin la oportunidad de
tener un juicio lluis Muñoz con los
detalles
el régimen de excepción en El Salvador
una medida temporal que cada vez es más
normal y es precisamente con el paso de
los días cuando aparecen más denuncias
de vulneración de los Derechos Humanos
María Leticia Escobar teme por su hijo
mi alma no tiene vida ahorita pues me
siento muy mal saber que mi hijo no sea
donde están y cómo está este temor se
fundamenta en Casos como el de Jesús
joya su hermano Henry fue detenido
después del estado de emergencia un mes
después desapareció de prisión tardó
cinco meses en saber que había sido
enterrado en una fosa común yo le dije
mi número le dejé mi
dirección y nunca tuvieron el valor de
avisarme de que Henry estaba enfermo de
que Henry había fallecido ni nada
entonces a mí eso me ha dolido mucho
porque hasta me lo enterraron pues sin
avisarme sin nada 80 personas han muerto
detenidas desde el inicio del régimen de
excepción sin haber recibido una condena
según la organización crisostal cerca de
3000 personas han denunciado violaciones
de Derechos Humanos dentro de las
prisiones desde el 26 de Marzo ha habido
55.000 detenidos muchos reivindican no
pertenecer a ninguna pandilla pero el
gobierno califica de innegable sus
resultados un solo pandillero una célula
de pandilleros
en las calles de nuestro país van a
tener la posibilidad de multiplicarse y
volver a generar el problema que
teníamos debemos de extirpar ese cáncer
total de la sociedad salvadoreña el 26
de Marzo las pandillas asesinaron a 62
personas el parlamento aprobó el estado
de excepción muy criticado por las
organizaciones defensoras de los
Derechos Humanos mientras el gobierno de
nayib bukele tiene un índice de
aprobación del 86%.
nos vamos a Nicaragua porque el gobierno
estadounidense impuso sanciones a 500
personas vinculadas al presidente Daniel
Ortega por socavar las instituciones
democráticas según dijo el secretario de
estado Anthony con este tipo de medidas
Washington Busca promover la rendición
de cuentas del mandatario a quien acusan
de reprimir al pueblo nicaragüense y
lograr la liberación inmediata de los
precios políticos los detalles nos los
entregaba previamente desde ciudad de
Guatemala nuestro corresponsal en
Centroamérica Andrés Suárez Jaramillo
Anthony blinken el secretario de estado
de los Estados Unidos Fue claro y
conciso dijo que ningún miembro del
gobierno de Daniel Ortega ni ningún
nicaragüense que facilite el abuso de la
represión por parte de la dupla de
Rosario Murillo debería pensar que puede
viajar libremente por los Estados Unidos
y de esta manera es que blingen el
secretario de estado sancionó a más de
500 funcionarios de vinculados con el
gobierno de Ortega además a sus familias
quienes ya no podrán Ingresar a los
Estados Unidos hablamos de miembros de
diferentes instituciones y de las ramas
del poder como jueces Fiscales policías
militares funcionarios de expresiones
altos funcionarios del Ministerio de
Educación entre otras personas que
estarían elaborando y beneficiándose de
políticas que socaven la democracia o
que estén impidiendo el retorno a la
democracia de este país centroamericano
sobre todo este año por la escalada de
la represión dado la persecución y el
encarcelamiento de sacerdotes de
periodistas de opositores políticos el
cierre de medios de comunicación la
expulsión e ilegalización de diferentes
organismos no gubernamentales en
síntesis una especie de estado del
terror otro de los argumentos de
Washington es que mientras Estados
Unidos y sus aliados están
luchando para responsabilizar a Rusia
por la guerra de agresión a Ucrania
Nicaragua es el país de América Latina
que está cooperando con
Moscú y de esta forma poniendo en riesgo
a toda la región así fue como justificó
hoy Estados Unidos todas estas sanciones
en contra de los miembros de el gobierno
de Daniel Ortega
y cerramos con celebraciones de
Halloween que ya empiezan a verse en
Estados Unidos más de 6.000 personas en
bicicleta vestidas como zombies y trolls
y cargando ataúdes y ambulancias
participaron del llamado Fantasy Fest
zombie right un evento anual que se
celebra en key West Florida y que
continuará hasta el 30 de octubre para
los próximos días se esperan concursos
de disfraces para mascotas y un desfile
de carrozas
de esta manera despedimos este
Informativo en francés 24 Gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]